Candace Cameron Bure her post fuller
house gig is taking her all the way to
Canada
but like Chris she's seeing that filming
in a pandemic comes with its own set of
safety rules we're abiding by all the
Canadian laws and we have to quarantine
we'll be the only two people in in a
home for two weeks until we get to start
productions Candice spent the fourth
quarantine in Vancouver with her
hallmark movie mom
Marilu Henner production on their Aurora
Teagarden mystery was shut down in March
a lot of people asked how did we get to
Canada with the quarter closed we are
considered essential workers because
without us they can't finish the film
and this film employs about 200 Canadian
people
yeah Vancouver is the third largest
location for TV and film production
after LA and New York
it adds three billion dollars and
700,000 jobs to the economy they told
you guys how things will change because
of safety with the pandemic yeah they're
definitely new protocols that we have to
follow if the shooting schedules are
taking longer in general because people
can't all be in the same room together
so the process will just take longer we
caught up with pandas as she was packing
for the two-month trip after she wraps
on her fourteenth Aurora Teagarden
mystery she starts production on her
ninth hallmark Christmas movie the
amount of luggage that I'm bringing is
actually ridiculous I have to bring
everything with me it can't go out can't
even go to a grocery store like nothing
I have a whole suitcase that is just
food which sounds crazy on one of those
Christmas movies Candice got to team up
with her 21 year old look-alike daughter
Natasha so Natasha do you watch that one
I not watch myself I literally cringe
another place you can see this
mother-daughter duo is tick tock I
didn't want to join now that I have I am
like down the rabbit hole it's fun
any tic TOCs she's done that have
embarrassed you that you've been like
mom be what I'm doing oh I'm really
trying to fill a singing video I was
trying to do it with my mother
and Natasha was like no I'm not letting
no she's like you know what no no just
take some out of tick-tock we're just
done
[Music]